[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
i would like to see more exclusive
events
on the east coast especially we don't
get a lot of them a lot of the bigger
events are basically on the west coast
in california this might be what i'm
hoping is the first of many yeah
in raleigh i've been really missing like
a retro game store of any kind i feel
like this is going to become like the
center for something really cool
we're about to go to the limited run uh
video game story physical very exciting
they got all the rare games in there
what are you looking for dude i heard
they do have scrunch i heard that they
do have that we're gonna play some
scrunt yeah i heard they have the
limited edition
mania that is a scary game it's like
castle you don't want to play that game
it's a dracula that is way worse yeah
it's so bad
i don't know what i know he's talking
about but it's terrible and yes
the new kirby the new yeah kirby i think
this one you can suck up
yeah yeah i heard
that's the rumor i don't know i heard
this kirby's rated m kirby get this one
yeah
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
oh
[Music]
bye
rated r p to m
[Music]
agent you're just in time we've been
looking for a bt specialist like you we
need your help
we have a hostage situation we just
received this video from the terrorist
leader
hello agents i see you've ignored my
demands we'll ignore this
[Music]
now that i have your attention we want
to play to south america and if not
all the other hostages will get it
[Music]
they're trying to leave the country you
want to know why
e3 trailers these guys got 300 kilos of
unauthorized trailers in that compound
that's why we need you agent the last
guy who had your job went missing two
weeks ago we found him on a beach in
mexico relaxing without a head this is
what we were able to recover from the
body
trailers let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
just
[Music]
river city girls 2.
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
looks like we found that missing
shipment of limited run games e3
announcements these guys thought they
could get away with stealing all our
trailers not on our watch watch out
we're under attack
good shooting agent i don't think any of
them survive you just saved uncle sam a
whole lot of court fees let's find out
what these guys had on them
trailers
let's see what this is all about
you wake up one day and find it's all
been a dream
where you wake up and discover you've
been asleep all the time and the
nightmare is real
report to precinct headquarters code
three repeat code
i'm mccoy lpd rep d-tech unit sometimes
we're called blade runners
[Music]
year and a half on the job it was still
the dirtiest work i'd seen
where's captain brian don't get too
excited the other blade runners are all
jammed up
mind if i ask you a couple of questions
two minutes that's how much time i give
every stranger that wanders in here off
the street you spawn anything you think
i ought to know about tell me
your suspect is obviously a replicant
a very dangerous one
i thought replicants were safe more
human than human
how about nexus 6. you know a lot about
them they're not killers detective
they're innocent they just want to live
a decent productive life like you or me
it's a very simple solution to an old
design challenge
give them jobs on earth and they will
never desire a different life
oh those skin jobs got no respect for
anything that truly lives and breathes
how did you feel about taking a little
test
you come into my shop and you want to vk
me
cough up some dirt early or i'm taking
this disc downtown
there could be a group of nexus 6's
tracking down genetic designers
there are things i want to know
take it easy big fella
i have nothing to fear from any of my
children you got the wrong place jack
they be holding you off the true life
building across town
i swear i want all the data you have on
replica dna structures mutation studies
everything i'm a blade runner you don't
believe me call lieutenant gosa we're
closed
we're not here to buy little man
believe me he's the least of our
problems you're talking crazy the hunter
be dangerous
[Music]
and he'll be dead
i don't know what you're talking about
you got any idea how glad i am to see
you no time for chitchat slim you want
to save your ass we got to blow this
joint right now i would prefer him alive
if possible and now it's time to end
this game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
wow those look fantastic let's head into
the comments wait i found some more
trailers in the bag
oh
uh let's watch this
[Music]
earth the not so distant future
solar flares and overcrowding have
destroyed the world's food supply from
our secret lab at ingest corp
bioengineering billionaire erika sores
creates an incredible breed of
eight-legged creatures with all the meat
and muscle humanity needs to survive but
will we survive the spider soul
[Music]
[Applause]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right now we can go in sir i found
one more trailer at the very bottom of
the bag
okay
let's watch that one
[Music]
uh
[Music]
that's a lot of good information but
there's even more inside sir
you'll never guess what i just found
more trailers
[Music]
huh
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
far in the future
earth was attacked by unidentified
aliens
the cities were reduced to wines
a single soldier is sent to battle
he is humanity's last hope
he is
[Music]
[Music]
rather a ranger or two
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
listen up new guy you might be the fancy
pants bt specialist but i'm still top
dog around here we got a report from hq
that mr super villain has a private zoo
on the property or he might be keeping
the payload i'm going undercover as a
zookeeper to see what i can find out pay
attention rookie you might just learn
something
look what i just found in the belly of
the beast
a trailer
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
these sith
they seek the death of all jedi
[Music]
we cannot hope to triumph against them
alone
[Music]
in the end i fear it may not be enough
you know not what path you walk jedi
she is no jedi you felt it she has lost
herself
in you we saw a wound in the force
in you
we saw the end of the force
and now
they shall see
what you
have becomes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
three
two
one
go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
inside this compound is the main
security force
i think we're about to get the jump on
them
there they are
[Music]
oh no the terrorists are aliens
oh man aliens this is so demoralizing
wait we're getting a call from hq
agents it's good to see you i hope
you're giving those bad guys hell i'm
here with some important messages from
our sponsors at pizza hut and limited
run games
pre-orders for teenage mutant ninja
turtles shredders revenge will open
and every copy sold through limited run
games and major us retailers will
include a free
pizza hut personal pan pizza and not
only that but they'll have a vhs style
classic edition that includes the game
in a steel book and a fully loaded
ultimate collector's edition that
includes an actual exclusive shredder
action figure from playmates and a
strategy guide and miniature arcade
replica
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now get back to your mission agents take
this free pizza hut personal pan pizza
to restore your health and power you up
cowabunga dudes
oh good the pizza hut transmitter is
working i feel
refreshed let's kick some alien ass
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good shooting agent let's see what these
aliens were getting up to
oh look at this
trailers let's pop these in see what
they're all about
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ziggurat interactive presets
american hero
[Music]
[Applause]
coming soon to physical through limited
run games
starring timothy bottoms
[Music]
it's gonna be an explosive summer
[Music]
american hero
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now ladies and gentlemen
let's get ready to rumble
[Music]
[Applause]